now to this story a lawyer for
conservative radio show host Alex Jones
says his client is nothing more than a
showman he made that claim in a Texas
Court where Jones is fighting to keep
custody of his children his ex-wife says
the views and conspiracy theories on his
radio show prove he's unfit to be a
father
opening arguments begin this morning and
a Warner looks at the implications of
this case for the right-wing media
pundit who claimed to have the
president's ear in a good morning good
morning Alex Jones runs a radio show
produced by his company Infowars he's
been accused of peddling fake news
stories to his audience but the idea
that Jones doesn't necessarily believe
everything he says may take some of his
fans by surprise the age of cowardice is
coming to an end the age of men will
return on his show Alex Jones has made
plenty about rageous and too many
offensive claims do you think you're
strong here's Jerry he's called the 9/11
attacks an inside job
the whole thing is a black hole of lies
and said the Newtown massacre was staged
the official story of Sandy Hook has
more holes in it than Swiss cheese New
York Times media critic Jim Ruttenberg
Alex Jones is the preeminent global
conspiracy theorist on the globalist
conspiracy
now Jones's lawyer says he shouldn't be
taken at his own work an Austin
newspaper reports Jones attorney Randall
Wilhite said at a pre-trial custody
hearing that Jones is playing a
character on his show and actually is a
performance artist he is the one who
says what's fake and what's real now if
his lawyer is saying he's fake it can't
get more treacherous for him his ex-wife
is fighting for custody of their
children claiming in court Jones is a
bad influence on their three kids this
is his son Rex on his father's show what
they're really trying to cover up is
much bigger than a little landfill
Rex was 12 years old when he made the
appearance he is undoubtedly cut out for
this and I intend for him to eclipse
what I've done Jones has a loyal fan
base his YouTube channel has more than 2
million subscribers
over 1.2 billion video views my way here
and Ruttenberg says many of Jones's
claims have been echoed by President
Trump when President Trump said the
mainstream press is covering up
terrorist attacks to you know cover for
Islamists that was directly out of Alex
Jones uber we reached out to Jones and
his lawyer his lawyer said they're
unable to speak because of a gag order
in the case meanwhile cliff Kincaid a
director of the right-wing watchdog
group accuracy and media told CBS this
morning Jones is not and never has been
a conservative Gael all right Anna
thanks very interesting story he lost
and hurt a lot of people with his claims
about Newtown saying that may not have
happened you think about the pain of the
families do yeah just hearing him say it
has a lot of holes is very hard to hear
mm-hmm that story continues